Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Astroneer.
Now I have been excited to play this game for a
long LONG time I heard about it first
right before I went to Cincinnati for
vacation but I wanted to play it back
here in LA because I wanted to
experience it fully I didn't- oh my god
(mark low key fangirling over game)
oh no. OH NO. oH YES! OH YESS! i'm sorry, i'm
geeking out a bit and there's a little
bit of lag probably because it's loading
an ENTIRE PLANET
OH GOD I love it I know next to nothing
about this game other than you are an
astronaut engineer and I-i love space
and also I used to almost be an engineer
myself so that can only mean that I'm
going to- absolutely freaking love is
what I'm doing what is my spaceship have
a dick
why okay you know what I'm just gonna
leave that the way it is
tab oh oh oh I'm tethered oh my god I
have no idea whats going whoa ok point
theres something over there
alrighty then terrain tool shape ter- what is
that oh I don't know what I'm doing
oh okay I've got power that w- hey fucking
god dammit ok so I've got power
compound needed solar I don't know what
any of this means but I love it lithium
needed battery
oh ok so I need to gather materials to
be able to do stuff I think and I don't
have enough materials to be able to do
that
Oxygen's at fifty percent that doesn't-
that doesn't seem good huh whoo I don't
know why I did that
yay! whoo okay
milder whoo kind of whoo okay I'm out of
whoos
oh no that's that's probably not how do
I oh I'm not tethered anymore
oh god that ok alright then well I need
to get some shit
it how did I pull out my oh that's right
collect resin ok oh no ohhhh yes
oh I'm accidentally terraforming
everything here but I'm just gathering
enough resources to be able to do what I
need to do ohhhhhh that's so cool oh that's so cool
oh man I can extend that why wait maybe
I should put away this tool here stand
whoa no way oh no way
WHOA (Mark is so amazed) cool that's awesome
okay so I need more- I need more resin I
don't know where to get resin I dont think
any of this is- this is resin this was
resin
heh sorry making a big old puddle here
*random noises* ok I got enough
for one unit of resin I'm out of power
help help me I need more power to be
able to do that powers over there
I did the resin wh- ayy I don't know what I
did but it's awesome and i love it
yay okay so I need I need to be able to
make oh this is like- thats awesome
oh that's awesome it is like Astrid it
it's it's astronaut engineering oh it's so
cool
give me some of that I need more power I
don't know how this is gonna be Power
exactly unless I'm just sucking lava out
of the planet itself but I'm not gonna
complain i can get all these organic
material now what kind of crazy ass tool
is ok wait I've got plenty of organic
stuff I don't need any more of that so
what I need to do is I need to extend
the range of this to be able to go
farther but I've got a lot of organic
stuff needed
I've got no copper no compound ooh its
getting dark
oh it's getting dark oh it's getting
dark but the sun's coming up
oh no that's a that that's an asteroid
or a moon or planet or something
uh-huh no oh my oh my god how deep does
this go
oh how deep can I make this I was
persistent enough would i be able to
burrow through the entirety of the
planet and if so that's fucking amazing
oh my god why can't my life be this
why can't my life be in space why can't I
be in space why can't i just be in space I just
really want to be in space guys (Mark desperate to be in space) okay so
i gotta find what is over there
*More random noises* I don't know what that is
over there but i want it i want it in my
backpack oh is- is that some sort of
living creature
what is that what are you gonna suck you
up
I don't know if I should have done that
but I did it Oh more power
I don't know how or why but I got that
ok i got plenty of power i got no space
for absolutely anything is that a crash ship oh
that's awesome i don't have enough power
to get over there but I'm gonna get over
there soon soon as I figure out what the
hell i need to do
ok but either way I need God ok so
backpack uhh compound aluminum man
we involve solar battery so i don't have
any of these compounds I need to make
some sort of a storage thing
oh that's right ah yeah okay so that's
good ummm
I could extend it out farther
no I don't have any resin dammit ok so
what I gotta do is I gotta go find resin
well i'm gonna explore a bit i'm gonna take a
little bit of oxygen with me and I'm
gonna I'm gonna go as far as I can and
try to explore the landscape to see what
there's something over there
it's some sort of looks like rock like
material maybe it's a copper maybe
because if I have copper yes no its
compound ok i do need this though
that's good i got compound whatever the
hell that means I've just got a random
assortment of compounds an amalgamation
if you will bobodybopbopbopbop
Oh
don't know maybe I could push this back
hey you're coming with me if I run out
of oxygen before I get you back i'm
going to be very pissed i'm just going
to play soccer with a ball of compound
real quick and I'll come back for you
*screaming* WILSON I'll come back for you ok bye *doodlydoodly*
i know i'm about to die I'm aware I'm
aware of this fact I know these things
I'm aware okay so what I need to do is I
need to I have two compounds smelter
*weird noise* printer maybe research I
could either make the research or the
smelter I'm gonna do the research first
yeah what yeah okay so now i need to put
in power
how do i do that how do i do that
tonight can I just inject oh no I need
to make like some sort of solar panel
right
also i need to figure out what to do
with all the plant material in my
backpack because that's just taking up
space and I don't need it here
what do i do about that alright i don't
know i don't know it's not telling me
exactly what I need but i need our man i
need to know so much more about this
I've got too much shit in my back can i
get rid of that though oh oh oh that's
handy
I don't know how that works but that's
handy that ok so i can just drop that
there and then come back for later
yeah okay alright enough getting excited
about this I'm sorry I'm freaking out so
much about this and I feel like I've
totally ignored you guys still talk to
him that I've been freaking out about
this this experience here but I freaking
love space i love the possibility that
we could conquer the stars even though
they probably won't happen in my
lifetime but i just love the idea like
the the idea th- goddamnit, just get that. fucking
just get. GET IN MY BAG!!
dammit how do i get you in my bag. just put it
there we go that's yep
BAM ok ok i just love the idea that we
can do so much more in this universe
than what we've done on this plant
because the universe is so incredibly
vast as no man's sky has showed us it
infinitely fast and infinitely boring
oh boy
what happens if I just dig myself into a
hole?
eh, probably nothing that shit got to dig my
way out of this one right there but
we're running out of oxygen
that's not good well i'm about to find
out what i do when i die
well that's not good okay well much like
sub nautica I forget to breathe a lot
and i'm about to run out of oxygen
i'm sorry, i'm sor- hey just you know
informative i'm currently suffocating
okay there we go
ok so i need to find a way to make some
sort of a god i need to find a way to
make some sort of a thing I need more
resin that's for sure but I doubt
there's any more resin down here
yeah doesn't seem to be anything I'm not
detected any resin but i'm using up a
lot of power that's for sure
ok so i need to go out and I need to
explore so I'm gonna go over here
there's a lot of organic materials but I
i'm wondering about this crashed looks
like a space shuttle or something like
that
I mean there was obviously people here
before us but maybe they're just other
people who like myself other failed
engineers that came out here and decided
to be terrible what they do I don't need
more compound I do need to find out what
this is all about why is this here?
Oh! resources thank you I'll take that yes
please power to- aack! can't see shit
can I see shit? copper yes please copper
yes please okay that helps thank you
I didn't even need to mine for it
I didn't even- what is that? what are you?
uu, can have you? what
oh cool but it's nothing is it ok?
I can't do that
ok gotta get out of here all I'm gonna
suffocate oh great
ah shit am I gonna make it this time the
answer is a solid maybe God why am I
such an idiot I'm an astroneer! I should
be smarter than this but I'm so stupid i
forget to breathe
this is why i could never actually be an
astronaut because i would totally forget
about the the the fact that i need
oxygen to survive
okay I did it I did it ok so what I need
to do is I need to make but I need to
make some sort of power thing and I
remember there was
copper? compound? Oh. No! compound can make a solar
panel so then if i take that solar panel
right there then i can apply power to
this thing question mark?
ok maybe if i make another one I can put
this on there to get power because
either way this is good because now I
have solar panels that can give me power
mobily so maybe I don't need to do that
anymore but if I could somehow transfer
one of these bad boys right there
yes look at and then I can do research
right Yes No maybe so
whoa look at research over there I don't
know what's happening but it's always
getting power all that's so cool
I don't know what its gonna research but
hopefully something good maybe I don't
know I'm just excited to be here I'm
just excited to be alive in this grand
time
okay but I still haven't discovered what
organic compounds are necessary for but
i'm going to explore out again to get
power I don't think it's all the way up
yet
ok that's getting power I'll be back in
a second and then I'll come back once i
find something else of value but I know
that I don't need power now what the
hell's that
oh it's a compass nice oh that oh that's
that's resin? I need that, I need that a lot!
primitive yep yep yep yep yep [Singing yeps]
ah shit I'm out of power oh
that recovers quickly i need to make
another one of these eventually but i
don't have enough compound for it gotta
get back before i suffocate again but
I've got a lot of resin which means that
I'm gonna be able to extend one of those
data oh there's another one over there
how did I miss that? cause I'm an idiot, that's why
now I got that
I should be able to make another one of
these two daddies if i put that there then
i can make a printer because i have two
copper little bingo Bongo I don't know
what this does but it's damn cool
oh that one solar panel feeds power to
all the other things that's awesome so I
i could make more than that but that's
so cool that it all shares the same
power source and I got one of my
backpack too but I guess when the sun
goes down I'm not gonna get any power of
that but that's so cool
oh I love that I love that I still don't
know how to use this but i love that
how do i use you i don't know but i have
you and that's all that matters maybe now I
can use plant material. where that plant material?
can I put you? wait what
the hell?
okay well I did that oh its storage
containers okay i think maybe I don't
know man I don't know I don't know what
to do with this
I don't know what to do with that I
don't know what to do with anything here
all I know is that I love it I love it I
love it all
it's all amazing and I like it a lot so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go get
more- hmmm, I have enough resin I guess
so what i can do is i can make.. I can make one of these?
I can extend this out so I
can just keep extending preferably and
i'm just going to get more resin there's
tons of it here
I mean I don't have a lot of power right
now but hopefully i'll be able to get
enough for a few slots- NOO! goddamnit give me power
nice oh so that's like a regenerating
source of power there
don't ask me how that happens I mean if
that happened in real life i guess it
would be sort of nice
oh wait it's called the SUN
*bobleedoo* and ok that should be everything
that i need for a few more
oh no I need just a little more. cmon show
me the money show me the resin show me
that sweet resin baby come on give it to
me
nope didn't get enough for a third one
but that's okay because i only need a
few more i'm just going to keep piling
out this way
nice ok so that's good so that's a nice
long chamber to be able to get power to
hold on each of these individually can
make another- that's so cool
god I need to stop saying things that
what is that why is it blue?
it's like the power things but it's blue
well I don't know what that is well I
don't know what that is
oh oh oh no oh I can make a trip for out
i can make a long trip i love that so
much
oh my god cave hell yes I'm going in
that oh my god a cave I don't want to go
in this oh no. what is that? what is that what
is it
compound I don't know its oxygen in here
oh god. are there monsters in this
oh no oh what is that it's moving it's
moving unknown unknown
I don't like that. uuegh I don't like that. I don't like that
at all
oh no you can get some more oxygen here it's
destroyed the entirety of the cave
system and find a way to tunnel out of
here
oh boy I hope I have enough power for
this I bet I don't
oh god that's not good oh boy oh boy
okay you know what before i go down into
the cave of death i would actually
explore the surface first and not die a
horrible painful death which I know you
guys would love to see and don't worry
I'm sure that's going to come in the
future but for right now I'd like to
survive just a little bit longer to be
able to explore this wondrous environment
and I finally found a way to get oxygen
so I'm able to go forward and i'm
assuming that eventually i'll be able
[Mark freaking out]
AAH!! what the fuck is that
uuueeghh, ueegh why is it pulsating ? oh why do all
aliens need to pulsate so much? you don't
want to touch it
oh fuck you so- EUGHH, geuh! fuckin' ewgh..
like worms but really solid stick like
worms. alright what do we got here anything
worth doing
can I bring some of these back eventua- oohh
apparently i can. oowh what am i
holding
how am i holding this why is it going
into the distance
well okay you know what I'm just gonna
use by incredible telekinesis ability to
bring this back whatever the hell it is
I did not see good thing anyway because
i'm almost at oxygen anyway least the
portable variety
this is so cool this is ludicrously cool
i am having the time of my freaking life
with this game
this is delightful and amazing and I
love every part of it
oh ok i don't know what I got Oh for
research
Oh perfect oh I put this on my research
thing
yes just please yes please god dammit
god dammit
there we go okay and then there then I'm
going to research that ok go for it
fuel condenser? GREAAT
I don't know how that worked and i'm not
sure what it did. I-I don't assume that
researchers a random chance but I like
your style so anyway this is all the
time and for the first episode of
astroneer. I want to play this game so
much more i am so intrigued by this
because number one I love anything to do
with space but also this is just
fascinating. This is just really cool this is
like ludicrously cool and moderately
scary because not only is space cool it
can kill you
pretty much everything in space exists
to kill you
we are not meant to live in space it is
supposed to be horrible and death like
and nothing should be there and yet I
can't help but wanting to go out there someday and maybe I will but
most likely i won't be able to but
there's a lot of fun thus far so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought that sound the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video, BUH-BYE!! :)